if the relation referred to above of the
organism to the natural elements does
not express its essence the notion of
end on the other hand does not contain
it it is true that for the observing
consciousness this notion is not the
organisms own essence but something
falling outside of it and is then only
the above-mentioned
external teleological relation yet the
organism as it has been characterized
above is in fact the real end itself for
sense it preserves itself in the
relation to another it is just that kind
of natural existence in which nature
reflects itself into the notion and the
two moments of cause and effect of
active and passive moments which were
the result of a necessary separating out
are brought together into a unity so
that here something does not appear
merely as a result of necessity but
because it is returned into itself the
last or the result is just as much the
first which initiated the movement and
is to itself the realized end the
organism does not produce something but
only preserves itself or what is
produced is as much already present as
produced
Hegel introduced a new and very
important perspective that we're going
to be taking really throughout the rest
of the work in talking about a
teleological relation or a relation in
terms of the end in the previous
paragraph in 255 now in paragraph 256
and the the paragraphs to follow he is
going to play that out more and unfold
what's contained in it and so you know I
want to caution you right away because I
know that some of the viewers have a
tendency to watch you know one video and
say aha here's the spot where Hegel
finally defines something he's not
defining the nature of an end or
teleological relations at this point it
is an unfolding process where we're
going to get something more complex and
more coherent at the end than at the
very beginning but we have to begin at
the beginning so what do we have so far
we've got you know this discussion at
the beginning as he says where we just
passed through so you know we had been
looking at natural elements what would
he was calling the matters and you know
when we think about what we're observing
in nature we're not just observing you
know meteorological phenomena or even
just you know geological matters or you
know geographical things we're really
concerned and not just in the present
but also in the past that he is living
in and also the further passages
recounting in organic nature and why so
well because we are a part of organic
nature and we live upon it because we
are organism so it really helps us to
know what we're doing about that and
because it
is a very large and significant part of
nature perhaps the most interesting part
depending on you know what kind of
respectively like or again person you
have so he begins by talking about this
relationship between the natural
elements we saw this in terms of say
climate or you know water air earth you
know these are basic things a ton of the
organism organisms really because we're
several different types of examples the
question is are we able to provide laws
in a full sense that articulate the kind
of necessity and the necessity would
work primarily this way where you know
for example animals that are in water
have the characteristics of the fishes
right it's not just a merely class
picket or II thing it's saying this
determines this and as you saw there's a
kind of freedom that we're gam Nature
has in comparison to the natural
elements and organic nature you might
say can if we want to use a fish both
work you kind of wiggle out of the net
right so we don't actually have the kind
of necessity that that people want to
say is there and instead he brings up
the notion of end and he says if the
relation of the organism to the national
of us does not express its essence the
notion of end does contain its essence
and remember essence for Hegel is not
just you know something that corresponds
to a definition it's also what has
prominence that which shows itself as
being determinative is being important
so the notion and roots back right I'm
not going to put that on the board any
more ease assume that you you know
automatically translate it in terms of a
teleological relation yeah
there's nothing really mysterious about
that tell us just means and which you
know is the same as it's back in this
case right and in French right
and so teleology
would be some sort of coherent account
of what the end is and how the end
functions so the question here is that
what is the end doing and what what is
going to be the end so he says it's true
that for the observing consciousness
this notion this notion of n is not the
organisms own essence with something
falling outside of it and that it is
then only the above-mentioned external
teleological relationship now that's one
way of looking at teleology when we
think about means and ends and purposes
and plans and intentions and all that
sort of stuff we might think for example
I'll use you know chalk is it so often
done in the past as an example why is
this truck the way it is right we could
you know aerosol distinguish for costs
for ways of causality we can talk about
that the matter of the truck you know
the calcium carbonate we can talk about
the form of the truck now we're actually
getting closer to the egg we can talk
about the efficient cause you know some
machine process you know squishing it
into this shape why this shape though
why like this
why cylindrical so that it can be used
to write on a chalkboard right otherwise
a big old chunk of rock and that's not
quite as efficient for writing on a
chalkboard
it's tailored to some sort of purpose
and somebody does that Taylor so you
know in the case of technology or
natural things that have been reworked
technologically we can say that the
enemy is really something external to
the thing because it has been supplied
to it you know if we want to pick a
really funny example people you know
viewed the human being and all the other
creatures by the way not just Christians
but Stoics and others before them as
having the sort of characteristics that
they do and the functions that they do
in order to be able to meet some
right in a very complex system events
Voltaire and Candide made fun of lioness
who didn't actually say this but lighten
its thought everything had its purpose
right and so what are yours for and
maybe noses if I remember right well
they're very well adapted for placing
our spectacles upon now clearly there is
no necessity for that you know rules the
rain that rules the relation between
glasses a technological artifact very
recent in time and ears which we humans
that for a very very long time right and
which serve other purposes they're not
they're not just for putting spectacles
on so sometimes we can go wrong in this
hey who wants to try to keep us on the
right track and there's going to be a
tension between teleology or the
teleological relation as an external
relation that you know so the organism
is for something and that's the way
that's why it is the way this and an
understanding of N and teleology is easy
to call this organism as an end as a
realized end where the organism itself
is the you might say the telly line
telly Aloha guising thing and so that's
reflected here in this this paragraph he
says the organism is the real end itself
why it preserves itself in relation to
the other and here the other is maybe
hasn't minded natural elements the
organism is able to preserve itself in
relation to its environment but we
should also keep in mind that this other
includes other organisms those which
would like to eat it those which would
like to prey upon it parasitically or to
make it decay or in fact it those which
would like to not be eaten by it but are
going to be invites and
later other organisms of its own kind
with whom it might enter that end up in
some sort of rivalry relation you know
depending on what's going on whether for
resources or for a reproduction so he
goes on and he says the organism is the
real end of stuff that preserves itself
in relation to an other and because of
this it's that kind of natural existence
in which nature reflects itself into an
ocean this is a very nice catchphrase
right nature reflects itself into an
ocean the natural world by virtue of its
processes generates beings organisms
that are complex enough to persist in
their being and weigh very different
than the paths in that ease say the
natural elements show or a composite of
natural elements like a rock shows right
a rock you can you can leave it there
for a long time an erosion will
eventually wear it away or whatever
other natural processes an animal will
get get out of there eventually a plant
may not be able to move but it will
certainly produce offspring or even you
know clones of itself and it will get
into some other better environment for
try to preserve itself so he goes on he
says a few other very interesting and
important things he says we have these
two moments with cause and effect asked
after the passive moments these were the
results of the necessary separating out
they are brought together in a unity in
the organism as net the organism is and
as somebody like Aristotle was willing
to call it a self move mover you know
now self moved that in the way it
necessarily that an animal is because we
could be talking about plants although
plants are in certain ways less of an
organism than our animals for us would
be like Hegel all right so he goes on
and he says because it's returning to
itself the last were the result the
result is the end what we're striving
for this is much the first which
the movement it is to itself the
realized end so there's a sort of
cyclical or a circular process here for
the animal by which it is continuing its
being but it is continuing its being as
a being in different places of being in
different attitudes of being whose parts
in fact may in large part be different
from from not necessarily moment to
moment the time to time being which is
constantly taking things in you know
putting things back out acting suffering
and acting and suffering not just in
relation to the other but in relation to
itself so he says the organism does not
produce something although it does
produce all sorts of things right but
preserves itself or what is produced is
as much already present as produced what
does an animal want to do one of the
things that it wants to do is to
preserve its being in existence and it
does that through this dynamic activity
through which it's related to its world
we must examine more closely this
determination of end both as it is in
itself and as it is for the instinct of
reason in order to see how the latter
finds itself therein but does not
recognize itself in what it finds the
notion of then then to which reason in
its role of observer Rises is a notion
of which it is aware but it is also no
less present to something actual and it
is not an external relation of the
ladder but its essence this actuality
which is itself an end is related
purposively
to an other which means that its
relation is a contingent one with
respect to what both immediately are
immediately both are independent and
mutually indifferent but the essence of
their relation is something different
from what they thus appear to be and
their action is a different meaning from
the one sense perception at first finds
in it the necessity and what in what
takes place is hidden and shows itself
only in the end but in such a way that
this very end shows that the necessity
has also been there from the beginning
the end however shows that this priority
of itself and that in the fact that
nothing else issues from the the
alteration resulting from the action
than what was already there or if we
start from what is first then in this
its end or in the outcome of its action
returns only to itself and through this
very fact it demonstrates itself to be
something that has its own self for its
end and thus as a Prius has already
returned to itself or is in and for
itself therefore what it arrives at
through the process of its action is
itself in an arriving only at itself it
obtains its feeling itself we have here
it is true the distinction between what
it is and what it seeks but this is
merely the show of a distinction and
consequently it is in its own self a
notion
heyyou begins paragraph 257 by pointing
out a double motive for further
examining this notion of f I mean we
could also add the motive it's pretty
interesting that's alright
but Hegel thinks that the reason why
we're plowing ahead with this is in part
to understand the nature of ends right
he says we need to examine this
determination both as it is in itself so
we want to see what it is for its own
sake but this is why I put this other
part on the board we want to see what
reason at this point in in the analysis
in this point of the history of
consciousness what reason makes it and
we're going to be focusing more on that
so what we're looking at here is not
primarily Hegel's philosophy of nature
in a fully developed sense we're looking
at Hegel or giggle is taking us along
looking at what reason is progressively
able to untangle from all of this and
notice at this point Hegel says
something really quite interesting so
observing reason is observing nature
it's observing organisms it's trying to
figure out how they work what's going on
now it's observing ends in organisms
it's come that far but it doesn't
recognize itself yet in what it's doing
why is this important well because
everything that is being said about
organisms here applies to the rational
animal par excellence human beings human
consciousness right so the the subject
the reasoning observing subject is not
yet realizing how much this this applies
to themselves that is an insight that
has to be worked out later on so he says
the notion of end
to which reason in its role of observer
arises is any notion on which it is
aware so it's not just a idea it's not
just something that's coming to a
through sense perception it's a notion
it's a complex conceptual you know
systematic dynamic assemblage over we
want to understand that but he says that
it's also no less present of something
actual fear critic right and we see how
this plays out so we what do they mean
they're we're looking at the world and
we're seeing organisms that are behaving
as as and now he says okay what is the
relation of the organism the end to its
other so far he's been talking about the
other in terms of natural environment
right buddy and we need to think of this
more comprehensively in terms of others
that are also other ends but that's
going to come in a little bit later
let's keep it fairly simple here so it
looks like there's a purpose in relation
to the environment right and that's what
we call a teleological relation that's
what we've been uncovered now from the
vantage point of mere sense perception
all this appears to be as he says
contingent what well because the two
poles if you like the organism then is N
and it's either the environment with
which it interacts both are present in
their immediate being and they appear to
be mutually different to each other so
that we're unable to generalize anything
you know we know what all sorts of facts
we can engage in what Hegel is earlier
called description but we're not able to
actually say anything that has the
status of law that brings the kind of
necessity that we want and we've seen in
the previous paragraph why that is the
case because it's not quite so easy to
do so with nature by itself but but even
more so with organic nature now all of
this
is going to be how it appears for
sense-perception
well none of this is really the case or
you can say that it is such a partial
perspective that the relative
correctness of it is so relativized that
it's not going to be of any use going
forward instead Hagel focus is back on
this you know reflexive relation the end
or the organism to itself and he says
that this is something hidden this is
something this is a very interesting
point now isn't it this is something
that's going to be discussed in in the
rest of the work as well when we're
talking about organic beings when we're
talking about you know beings that react
to their environment and that can even
start to even you know react in ways
that seem to be adaptive or strategic
then we're talking about beings that
have a kind of interior already that is
not immediately evident to sense
perception or even to the sort of
inferences that the understanding might
might draw from from that right here
we're dealing with something that Hegel
is going to say is actually an ocean so
he says the actuality which is an end is
related purposively to to another right
the essence of their relation is
something different from what they
appear to be and their action has a
different meaning from the one sense
perception it first finds in it that's
probably the term uh sure that's put up
here it's not just that there's a
reflexive relation this is a reflexive
relation when we get rid of the kin just
assume that it's hidden back there this
is the reflexive relation through action
it's not just a navel-gazing
contemplation sitting by oneself
you know however one wants to pick
that the stone heated room the you know
the the thought thinking itself the
person mumbling to them soft laugh in
the corner as they do their meditation
no none of that happens most we
understand those arts of things in terms
of action rather than just a lot we
don't have what's going on here but
really what we what's going on here is a
dynamism of action within love the world
but action which concerns the organism
so he goes on he says the necessity in
what takes place is hidden and shows
itself only in the end but in such a way
that this very and shows here's where it
gets really interesting this necessity
has been there from the very start we're
discovering this is what reason does
right reason discover is what is out
there in the world for it to find
because reason is already out there
waiting for it to find itself not
realizing that that's the case the end
once it becomes even you know you might
say minimally conscious of its own
existence as an end is already being
moved by this internal necessity so when
we talk about teleological relations we
can think in terms of you know say
ordering and technology that you know
the human being super imposing order and
be God doing stuff from up on high and
then we can think of the thing itself as
having the the living thing itself as
having its own teleology within it that
has to be unfolded which is perhaps not
entirely aware of but is acting on the
basis so he googles of them he says the
end shows his priority of itself and the
fact that nothing else issues from the
alteration resulting from the action
then what was already there in and
continuing its being that is what it is
do it again is this
remind us of you know Aristotle again
Hinkle is a big fan of airsoft by the
way I don't know why people are always
wanting to go too straight to be honest
when Aristotle might be more helpful
sometimes for understanding hey well
that's an aside
Aristotle will we'll talk in terms that
are that are kind of similar here I'm
going to go back to this the N it shows
that this priority of itself and the
fact nothing else issues from the
alteration resulting from the action
than what was already there this is
similar to what Aristotle calls it
praxis which we translate is action
whose end lies in itself not all things
are done for the sake of something
outside of the process itself here Hegel
is talking about the thing you're ganna
thing and as continuing as maintaining
as augmenting its own existence and the
point of that thing
and notice that this is a very specific
also very individuated he's not going to
spelled it out here but myself as an
organism yes I may be devoted to
continuing the human race as something
in being but I sure as hell am bent on
continuing my own existence in being
right I'm not so bent on continuing the
little fluffy rabbit that maybe I want
to eat and skin and use up in existence
because they taste good and they make me
feel good and they are meant to my being
right so worrying off salad if you like
you know the broccoli whatever so that
you says it you know in the argument is
actually returns only to itself truth is
very fact it demonstrates it to be
something that has its own self for an
end it has its own self where it he
calls it a Prius there something that is
prior it you know this doesn't mean that
its existence you know pre-exists itself
right he's not saying yeah but there by
the time
it is engaged in this there's already a
necessity present so he says that what
goes on in here is this kind of being
shows itself as being in and for itself
which is always a good thing from a
Hegelian perspective right he also talks
about it as sort of producing and this
amounts to reproducing itself and here's
where it gets really interesting he's
talked in the past about self
consciousness is feeling of itself and
we're going to start talking about self
consciousness and just a little bit this
is where the living being does in fact
experience its feeling of itself now it
may not have a cognitive relation to
itself right we think that many animals
at least are not self-aware in a
cognitive sense but they certainly are
conscious of themselves in an affective
sense right
pull the dog's tail it's not just a
stimulus reaction that dog gets angry
and you know shows an anger response
tries to bite you barks at you and it's
not you know when you pull somebody
else's tail almost that dog cares about
that other dog or identifies with it in
some way there's there's a a self
relatedness right so all of this is
involved in this notion of end you see
how much there is contained within it
and remember where is Hegel going with
this he's not just trying to make sense
of the notion of n he's trying to see
where reason enters into this
but this is just how self-consciousness
is constituted it likewise distinguishes
itself from itself without producing any
distinction hence it finds in the
observation of organic nature nothing
else than a being of this kind it finds
itself as a thing as a life but makes a
distinction between what it is in its
what it is itself and what it is found a
distinction however which is not just as
the instinct of the animal seeks and
consumes food but thereby brings forth
nothing other than itself so to the
instinct of reason in its quest finds
only reason itself the animal finishes
up with the feeling of self the instinct
of reason on the other hand is at the
same time self-consciousness but because
it is only instinct it is put on one
side over against consciousness in which
it has its antithesis its satisfaction
is therefore shattered by this
antithesis it does indeed find itself
that is the end and they likewise this
end is a thing but firstly the end is
for that instinct outside of the thing
presenting itself as an end secondly
this end qua end is also objective and
the air for does not fall within the
observing consciousness itself but in
another intelligence
in paragraph 258 we appear now to shift
gears in a way because by the end of
this paragraph what we're finding is
that observing reason or consciousness
and the action in this case
self-consciousness is discovering that
what we thought was the end present and
the thing that is you know living that
is organic turns out to be outside of it
but outside of it only for a particular
kind of thing in this case namely for
self-consciousness which is going to
find the end in another being so let's
see how how we we get to that point says
all the stuff that we've been looking at
so far particularly in 256 into 57 where
we realized that the the end the organic
you know being or creature or thing as
an end has this intensive reflexive
relation to itself through action where
it really is its own end it is its own
essence in a way that nonliving things
aren't self consciousness is a thing
like this do you remember when we had a
similar realization it was at the
beginning of the self consciousness
section wasn't it and we're gonna see a
little bit of that ground retraced here
this isn't a good example of a galleon
sublation the stuff that was essential
in the path we traversed in the past
turns out to get reincorporated or you
might say not even necessarily be
incorporated as it would have been left
of the sign but rather brought back to
prominence so hitting who says this no
self consciousness is this constituted
it distinguishes itself from itself this
is something of the essence of self
consciousness are you paying attention
right now if you are you know you just
get it you
act of distinguishing yourself from
yourself if you ask yourself wait as I
can have them was I paying attention
you're taking a position on you that is
the same you that's taking the position
so Hagel will call this a act of
distinguishing where there actually
isn't any distinction that's a you know
what you're sheet there's no splitting
you can't get away entirely from
yourself that's the nature of
self-consciousness right yeah and it's
going to turn out that that is going to
get projected in other ways as well so
he comes on and he says it finds in the
observation of organic nature nothing
else that it being of this kind so
self-consciousness and this this you
know intensively related organism is
observing the rest of organic nature
which now understands to be all these
different creatures and things that are
ends and it finds itself out there as
well so he goes on and he says it finds
itself as a thing as a life but makes
the distinction between what it is
itself and what it has found a
distinction however which is none so we
see this same process of making a
distinction which isn't really a full
distinction so you might say that this
over here is also encompassed within
self-consciousness right it's getting
very complicated very quickly incident
so he says just as the instinct of the
animal seeks and consumes food but
thereby brings forth nothing other than
itself you know what happens when an
animal consumes its food it makes more
animal there replaces the parts that are
dying or it takes that that you know
sustenance and turn
it into little versions of itself think
about a tic for example pretty simple
organism only has two senses as far as
we know mostly a blood factory that
takes you know blood and turns it into
new little baby tics that's that's that
seems to be its purpose but that is a
purpose for it right
self-consciousness of course is much
more complicated than that but he goes
on he says the incident of the animal
seeks them consumes food thereby brings
forth nothing than itself so the
instinct reason what kind of beings are
we you know when we talk about ourselves
as being rational beings this is a total
side note but it is very interesting to
think about sometimes people think about
rationality as if it's just like it's
some logic circuits put some input in
you get the necessary answer I provided
the machinery isn't screwed up inside
that's not the way rationality works not
even rationality in terms of instinct on
the other hand it smell like pure
freedom like you're just you know you
can look at anything and decide to put
anything together in any way whatsoever
in fact to become rational as a process
in which you're using what momentum of
rationality you've got to work with that
the start probably provided to you in
through your interactions with others as
well as something that's part of our
being and you try to augment it all
right that's that's an interesting
digression but I'm not going to spelled
it up further here
so he says reason in its quest finds
only reason itself the animal finishes
up with the feeling of some animals do
imitated self-awareness not necessarily
a full-blown reflexive kind of their
self-awareness although some will
certainly seem to have that not new many
animals we're animals too right
so by you know some animals definitely
do have that reason is at the same time
self-consciousness
but because it is only instinct at this
point
says it's put on one side over against
consciousness in which it has its
antithesis or opposition
so it's satisfaction is shared by this
it does find itself right those by
itself out there in organic nature yes
an end and likewise this end is a thing
but he says firstly the end is for that
instinct outside of the thing presenting
itself and what is the thing this is
over here some consciousness finds
another sub consciousness yeah and then
he says secondly this adequate end is
also objective and therefore does not
fall within the observance itself but in
another intelligence so what do we have
here the other self consciousness is
related to itself it's also related to
its other in which it finds itself
you